- Well, I have to go to this
one because "Hands Clean,"
I've actually covered that on this show.
I know, right?
(audience laughing)
I know, I know.
I get that gasp.
But it's the things you talk about.
They're just so poignant.
Like people, they don't
know how to word it.
And you have this very amazing way
of saying what we really wanna say
or we don't know how to
identify it, and "Hands Clean,"
I mean, that's a really rough song.
Is that from like childhood trauma and on?
- Mm-hmm.
- Gah!
- Yeah, young teen-
- There's a lot
in those lyrics.
- Yes.
And when I first wrote it,
I remember the record company having said,
"Let's do this video where it's a karaoke
and there's kids and it's joy."
And I asked them, I said,
"Have you heard the song?"
(audience laughing)
And they said, "Yeah, it's great."
I was like, "Okay, so you
haven't heard the song.
Alright."
- Oh!
- It just felt like this
incongruent kind of thing.
But it actually was a lovely way
to present a song that otherwise
might not have even been
listened to, I think.
- Absolutely. That's what I'm saying.
You have this very catchy way,
but bringing your like, (chuckles)
Webster dictionary words...
(all laughing)
I'm like...
Do you know that? This is not a lie.
I bought my first
dictionary because of you.
- I didn't know what I was talking about.
(audience applauding)
- I was like, I dunno how
old. I was very young.
And I was like, "What are these words?
They mean something and I
just need to look them up."
And literally, you are the
reason why I owned a dictionary
for the very first time.
But you are, you're such
a great teacher in that
and you're very clever at putting it
in such a pop like rock like element
to where it's catchy
enough in the pop way,
but it's rock and
alternative and raw enough
that it's like cool and indie.
Like, I don't think anybody's ever
done you.
- Bridged those worlds?
- Yeah. Yeah.
I don't think, and since then.
- Well, it's a combination
of love for the entertainment
and the presentation and the performance
which I live for.
And then I also live for the not precious,
dirty birdy, just go for it
and don't worry about it.
Don't censor.
So a nice combination is my fantasy.
- I love that it's uncensored. Ugh!